[Music]
protesters in central London
angry at mayor Sadiq Khan's plans to
expand a scheme that charges polluting
cars to drive in the capital we got a
cost of living crisis right now we've
got people that haven't got money for
the gas the electorate they're
struggling mortgages everything is going
up and now Sadiq Khan has come along and
saying we're going to bang you with 12
pound 50 a day if it's not 12 pound
fifty go and buy yourself a new car if
you can't get a new car you're basically
screwed
there's a scrappage scheme to help but
these campaigners say it's not enough
probably with the majority of
politicians they don't live in the real
world they haven't got a clue what it's
like to try to survive I don't have a
compliant vehicle it's as simple as that
I can't afford the compliant vehicle his
absolute rubbish
Scrappy scheme two grand big deal who
pays for the rest of it such is the
extent of the anger some have gone
further than protest an anonymous group
calling themselves the Blade Runners
have been targeting new cameras pulling
them down and slowing progress
the ultra low emission zone or Euless
originally covered just Central London
in 2021 it expanded to a wider area
still part of a plan to tackle air
pollution
at the end of August though it's going
to include all London boroughs
it's already become a point of
contention in the run-up to next year's
mayoral elections Euless isn't just a
political problem for London's mayor
it's becoming a legal issue too with
five conservative-led councils forcing a
judicial review that's due to be heard
in just a few days time
support from King Charles to deliver
more green policies will have been
welcome for a mayor Under Pressure
fighting to keep his Flagship policy on
the road is there a war on motorists on
your watch in London absolutely not
absolutely not but there is a war on air
pollution there is a war on premature
deaths of londoners there is a war in
relation to climate change it's really
important that we realize it's not Us
Versus Them All of Us benefit from uh
cleaner air all of us benefit from fewer
admissions hospitals because of
respiratory issues all of us benefit
when people aren't taking time off work
because they've got ill health
there are low emission zones in other UK
cities and many more planned in the
coming years all of them will be
watching the battle in London closely as
a test of people's tolerance for change
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News